difference between you hating and loving
your life is perspective as marcus
irelia said the impediment to action
advances action what stands in the way
becomes the way that negative situation
that you're facing right now will define
you either you succumb to it and you
hate your life forever or you rise above
it and it becomes the greatest blessing
of all time the choice is yours and i'm
going to show you how to conquer it so
you may have noticed that i have this
arm band on this really colorful armband
what's the story i have this on as a
reminder to stay in a beautiful state
it's a reminder to myself every day now
naturally i'm pretty optimistic and
happy and positive and i've trained and
worked on myself to be even more
optimistic and happy and positive and
consume things that make me even more
happy and optimistic and positive but
there's still some times that i feel
negative there's still some times that
i'm not proud of myself the classic
example for me is when i get interrupted
if i'm working on something and i'm in
the zone and i'm focused and i'm
building momentum and somebody
interrupts me i can be really short i
can be really rude i'm not gonna say
anything offensive or something that i
would regret but i could be short and
rude i want to change it i don't want
anything to knock me out of my beautiful
state at least that's my ambition that's
my intention that's my goal if i can get
closer to it i'll be pumped it's the
perspective shift and so part of my
daily routine is i put this on i don't
sleep with this on at night i'll take it
off and then part of my morning routine
is i'll put this on and it's a reminder
as i put it on that i want to stay in a
beautiful state today i might get
interrupted but i want to be proud of
how i deal with it and then i look at it
every day it's hard not to right it's
not just some little tiny wristband it's
giant and it's colorful and it stands
out and it's a reminder every day and
also something that when i'm talking to
people they'll ask me about it because
it's a conversation piece why am i doing
it right people are curious they want to
know and so every time somebody asks me
about it it's a chance to tell the story
again and in telling that story even now
as i'm telling this story it reinforces
for me this is why i have it on this is
why i'm doing what i'm doing and so
having some kind of trigger that brings
it up it really works for me i think it
could work for you as well rule number
two craft your grandao george bernard
shaw famously said the reasonable man
adapts himself to the world the
unreasonable one persists in trying to
adapt the world to himself
therefore all progress depends on the
unreasonable man the entrepreneurs who
win are the unreasonable women and men
who are trying to make a difference
you're different you don't fit in stop
trying to instead make the world adapt
to you i want to tell you a story about
guanyu and his guan dao
let me get my prop so this is a heavy
statue made of bronze
let's hope my death doesn't collapse
from this
we good can we see okay good this is
guan yu guan yu is a legendary uh
chinese general god of war
and he was a huge man in chinese history
he was huge by by stature giant he was
bigger than everybody else that he was
fighting against so when he was getting
started in fighting when people gave him
a regular sword or staff or spear it was
so light for him it was too easy for him
because he was such a giant beast of a
man
and so instead of just taking the tools
that everybody else was using he made
his own weapon called the guan dao it's
this it's this crazy thing right here
it's this crazy you know staff with a
giant blade on the end of it guan dao
nobody else could lift this thing
because it was so heavy
but he had it crafted for him because he
could lift it and it made him even more
powerful than everybody else because he
had this giant weapon that he was using
in all of his fights that's what i think
entrepreneurs need to do that's what you
need to do you are a genius you are
michael jordan at something you are guan
you at something the greatest fighter in
china at the time right that's you at
something
and for you to win
you need to have your own guan dao
you need to craft your weapon craft your
business craft your habits craft your
activities craft the people around you
so that you can leverage what you're
naturally great at i make videos right i
love having my own message i love djing
content
it's what i love doing
i can make four videos a day across my
channels because i have a team of people
who helped create all of this stuff if
it was just me doing everything i would
not be making the content that i am
i built the business around me what i'm
great at what i love doing what i want
to continue to excel and improve on you
need to find the same thing for you you
are a guanyu you are a michael jordan
it's time to embrace that and then
create something that hasn't been
created before that's what entrepreneurs
are doing create your guan dao to let
you do what you're so good at at an even
higher level rule number three don't
stay in mediocrity if you are the most
ambitious person that you know you are
going to play small for life look around
at your friends your family the people
that you hang out with what do they want
out of life if you're the one always
pushing them and no one's pushing you
guess what happens you don't get the
push that you need and you stay in
mediocrity being the best in a group of
unambitious people so i just came back
from an event in florida that i was
doing a keynote at and at the end i
challenged an entrepreneur who showed up
to make some changes on his youtube
channel we met over dinner i helped him
with his youtube channel it was him and
his business partner sitting there and i
said by tomorrow here's what i want you
to do i want you to go in and make sure
you have
these things updated and he said yes
i'll do it i said it's important to do
it by tomorrow because i'm still here
i'm still here in the morning if you
need anything you can ask me face to
face while i'm still here before i fly
home to toronto yes i'll do it next
morning comes around
we show up at a meeting i got a meet up
happening we got i don't know 30 people
who showed up to to meet with me
and i see him out of the corner of my
eye sitting at the back of the room and
i say hey did you do the thing that i
told you to do
i said no i didn't do it
i said why what happened
said well we we were doing lots of other
stuff it's been a full day you know we
had this entire day of of speaking and
meeting people and then so much
information went home we were doing all
this kind of work
okay great but what about the promise
that you made to me to do it and then
his business partner chimes in and said
you know it's actually my fault i told
him evan's probably not gonna notice
he's not gonna remember don't worry
about it we'll take care of it when we
all fly back home and so i told him
don't let your business partners low
standards prevent you from moving
forward on the things that you said you
were going to do
staying committed to the thing that you
say you're going to do your word to
yourself is the whole game forget about
what you just say to other people what
do you do for yourself because we're
often looking for no's we're often
looking for somebody else to give us a
break right he's been working hard and
and he is i know him and i know his
business partner and these guys are not
slackers they're not slackers and and i
was poking a little bit at his business
partner saying his low expectations his
low standards but in this situation it
was true
the entrepreneur that i was speaking to
said he was going to do this thing by
tomorrow morning before he came and went
to my event he would do it
and his business partner says he's not
gonna remember don't worry we've worked
too hard already let it go we'll do it
when we get home and they would do it
when they got home i know they would
he's looking
for the reason not to do it
when you say you want to hit the gym
when you say you want to hit these
business goals when you say you want to
have this outcome and be proud of the
effort that you put in every day when
you say that you're going to do
something there will be moments where
you want to let yourself up the hook
where you say i work so hard or i'm so
tired or i deserve a break right this is
the language you use to yourself and so
when that happens you're looking for
affirmations from the people around you
and if you are the most ambitious person
in your friend group if you are the most
ambitious person what's gonna happen
they're gonna say you already worked so
hard anyway what are you talking about
yes of course give yourself the break
and it's the exact answer that you're
looking for because you want to give
yourself a break
now if you're proud of your effort maybe
you should take a break but it's not
because somebody with lower standards
gave you the pass
it's because you're proud of the effort
that you put in and so this is where it
gets really dangerous when you are the
most successful the most ambitious
person from the people around you
they're always going to give you a
reason to play smaller
you can't accept it you have to push
through you need to change your
environment rule number four start for
free the free leads you to the paid if
you have no momentum no traction no
clients then start for free prove your
worth and build momentum give them
something they can't wait to have again
and pay for this time the goal isn't to
do free forever but the free gives you
the thing that you're missing the most
which is momentum in your business so
i'm pre-launching my book right now
built to serve and people who buy the
book and pre-order also get access to my
private facebook group where i help
people one-on-one every week and so the
guy that i had on last week is a coach
he's a health coach he wants to help
people make transformations to their
health because he made a radical shift
in his health as well
and i said great well how are you doing
right now well i have a couple clients
but i'm still working at a restaurant i
want to be able to leave that so i can
focus on this full-time awesome if
you're a coach what i need to see you is
coaching i need to see you coaching
people what i'd love to see now is an
instagram live regular show
and what do you do on your instagram
live you bring on people who need help
being coached through a health
transformation because it's one thing to
say i'm a coach and i help people get
these results it's another though to
actually see people change
to have you go alive with them
one-on-one and help them bust through
their limiting beliefs and their mindset
and the issues that they're dealing with
and then to come out on the other side
by the end of the call feeling hope
feeling invigorated feeling inspired
because people will watch that and say
man
i want a result like that they see
themselves in the client that you're
helping and they then want it for
themselves now you get two versions one
will be free people
one would be like can you do me i i'll
take it for free
which is great don't say no don't get
discouraged don't get upset you want the
free
because the free gives you the content
and so if they're willing to come on and
do live on instagram with you for free
then you do it
and there'll be other people who say hey
i love what you're doing i need a
radical transformation in my health as
well
but i don't want to be on instagram i
don't want to make it public can i can i
hire you
privately bingo right that's what we're
looking for that's when you start
getting paid the free leads to the paid
if you want to have more confidence and
motivations check out our 254 series the
link is in the description below and
what you need to do is inoculate
yourself against the judgment and learn
to take action on your ideas because the
alternative is a life filled with regret
it's got to be your life's work if you
only have to write one book ever in your
life this is it and it's got to be
amazing find whatever the smallest first
step is and then the smallest next step
is and continue to build those steps and
when you look back you'll have realized
that you made some pretty significant
progress rule number five focus on the
right thing one of my favorite quotes of
all time is whether you think you can or
you think you can't you're right it's
usually attributed to henry ford from
all the videos that i've made all of the
successful people that i profiled from
industry titans to monks one of the
things that they all have in common is
the ability to focus on the things that
they can do to improve their situation
there are a million reasons why your
idea will not work out and ate while it
will successful people focus on the
eight reasons why it will succeed and
unsuccessful people focus on that
million reasons why it won't so it's
time to decide which one are you rule
number six stop making excuses smart
people come up with really smart reasons
why you can't do something and it's true
there are a million reasons why you will
not win a million reasons but there are
eight reasons why you will and you have
a choice this is an important choice you
have to decide are you going to focus on
the million reasons why you are not
going to win or on the eight why you
will so let's talk about being an
introvert
i'm an introvert i still am an introvert
i own my introvertedness
that often doesn't come across you may
not believe me you might see these
videos and think evan is so extroverted
type a personality i'm not
uh i i get nervous in big rooms i don't
like hanging out with strangers i never
talk to the people next to me on flights
or the train or anything i don't go up
and say hi and introduce myself i hate
all that stuff i hate small talks i have
zero need to be around people
if it's just me and my wife i'm happy i
have zero need for contact to fill my my
social
equation whatever you want to call it
i'm introvert i still am but i i use it
as a positive where it used to be really
strong negative i used to get into a
fight all the time with my agent and he
said the problem with you evan is you
don't want to be famous it's like you're
right i don't i don't need to be famous
i don't need the spotlight i don't want
the spotlight
and it finally sunk in that in order for
me to get my message out there the more
known i am the more people hear the
message and so how does an introvert
become famous well we'll see join me on
my journey we're on we're in this
together we'll find out together
but the thing that gets me through all
of it is one going in on the strength
and and turning that introvertedness
into not an excuse but into something
that's empowering i think as introverts
we listen better
i just came back from an event in
florida where
somebody at the dinner table was saying
evan it's really surprising how well you
listen
yeah because that's all that's all i do
i focus on the person i'm talking to
i'm introverted it's not about me
talking it's about you trying to get a
result i want to help you get a result
and so introverts are fantastic
listeners
and so you actually want to help people
make a change you want to help be a
great salesperson you want to help be a
great speaker you have to know your
audience you got to know who you're
talking to you got to be a great
listener i think that comes from being
introverted
and the second thing is having the
passion and the purpose behind what
you're doing gives you the strength and
courage to do things that are scary
getting up on stage and speaking is
scary for me my biggest fear is is
letting people down my biggest fear is
i'm going to disappoint somebody
and so when i go on stage just always a
fear in the back of my head is that i'm
going to disappoint these people that
they're not going to feel like they got
their money's worth
when i did my tour earlier this year
that was my biggest fears every four
days i'd be taking a new stage in a new
city and i would just let people down
and i got to face that fear every day
every four days why because the purpose
it means something
and so yes you might be introvert yes
you might have a whole bunch of reasons
why you can't win but the people who win
look at your heroes look at you look at
the people who you love when you look up
to look at who you respect look at who
you want to be be like look at their
story look at where they came from
chances are they came from a worse spot
than what you currently have right now
the opportunities of resources the
connections they had was worse than what
you currently have at your disposal
right now the only difference between
them and most people is they focus on
the eight reasons why they could win and
most people focus on a million reasons
why they're gonna lose rule number seven
don't tie yourself worth to winning
you're afraid of experimenting because
you tie yourself worth to winning
instead of trying if you base your
self-worth off how much you win then
you're only going to try things that you
have a good chance of winning at thus
you play small for life
but instead if you base yourself worth
on trying on the effort that you're
putting in you will fail on most days
but you'll end up accomplishing more
than you ever thought was possible so
every time i go to our youtube event i'm
always being praised by my thumbnails
people always say evan's got the best
thumbnails go look at his thumbnails
model his thumbnails use them as an
example for the best practice and i i
internally i'm always saying our
thumbnails suck we need to get better
sure we might be among the best but we
need to get better we could be way
better than we are right now
why have we become the best
because i'm experimenting constantly
most of my tests do not work i use a
tool called tubebuddy shout out to buddy
huge fan we've done over 1100 split
tests on our thumbnails where we run one
thumbnail against another and one
against another one against another
trying to beat our best and most of the
experiments don't work they just don't
work i recently ran an experiment of on
my main channel putting my face on the
thumbnail with the youtube white border
uh against tony robbins and it tanked it
was like 80 percent worse
than our current thumbnail and that's
okay people don't like my face next to
tony rowan's that is okay i'm fine with
it i expect to lose i expect everything
i do not to work but i'm willing to test
it to see
i just recently came up with one
thumbnail design where i made the
background purple instead of black
purple instead of black and it actually
did better it did significantly better
and so now i'm testing it out on five
more thumbnails let's see does the
purple one do better than the black one
if that works out maybe i rolled it out
across the entire channel but it's very
rare that i find the win
out of the 1100 experiments that we've
done most of them will not work will
never work even from the beginning i'm
thinking this is probably not gonna work
but i'm willing to test that's okay even
if the most likely outcome is failure
it's worth the test to see rule number
eight make proper decisions you need to
make the big decisions in life with your
heart and the small ones with the head
big decisions with the heart small ones
with your head why
because your head only understands a
world that currently exists it's logical
it's practical it keeps you safe but
your heart can create something new that
hasn't existed before it's why the
number one rule for success is follow
your passion all progress depends on
what your heart tells you to do and then
you use your head to figure out how to
execute it so i just got back from an
event that i was keynoting in florida
and i was meeting these two
entrepreneurs and helping with their
youtube channel and one of them is a
really logical head first guy and the
other one is a more heart based
passionate guy and they were they're
asking me so that they're partners in
the same business and they're asking me
what's more important
logic or emotion
logic or emotion
and they're obviously the guy who's
logic based thinks logic is most
important and the guy who's emotion
based thinks emotion is most important
right you want to think that what you're
great at is the most important thing and
i told them it's macro emotion
micro logic
macro emotion micro logic you need to do
both so as i'm looking at their youtube
stats i'm going deep into youtube i'm
telling them all the data they need to
know i'm looking at the numbers and
explaining your audience retention sucks
here we need to fix it the percentage of
subscribers coming to your channel is
too low all of this stuff we're going
we're going deep into all their
analytics i can talk numbers for days i
love numbers i love making data-driven
decisions but it's not the macro the
macro is the heart the macros why are
you on youtube right why am i on youtube
why am i making videos that's the macro
and then you use your head to figure out
the how the science of the thumbnails
and the audience retention and the
playlists and the titles and all of the
micro strategies that you can use on
youtube to grow
but it's macro motion micro logic
and so as i was explaining it to him as
i said it was listen it's macro emotion
he said but but i was listening to you
as you were explaining things to me
it was very logical
like yes
the tactics were very logical but the
delivery so that you would understand it
and then go home and actually apply it
is emotion
it's not logic
it's emotion because logic can be
everywhere the answers can be everywhere
you know how to lose weight you stop
eating junk you know how to get fit
you'd start working out
you can find it but why are people not
doing it
because you haven't connected
emotionally the reason why you
understood what i was saying and you're
willing to take action is because of the
way that i delivered the information to
you
because i had you control the mouse and
go through and do it yourself because i
was encouraging to you when you needed
it and i hit you in the face when you
needed it too
not with my hand with words
right it's macro emotion micrologic you
need both to win but just recognize the
situation you're getting into your big
decisions with the heart and then you
use your head to figure out how to do it
so it's common when you come with a new
idea for something you make a list of
pros and cons right and that's your
heart often talking against your head
where you have this giant list and you
say well these are all the reasons not
to do it but there's only one reason why
i want to do it and so if it's 10 con
and one pro what do you do
if you just look at numbers you go for
the con but maybe the one reason why is
you just love it
when your head and your heart are
working together it's easy when you're
heading your heart or opposite that's
when it slows momentum that's when
nothing happens because you want to do
it but it doesn't make sense to do it
you really love it you have to do it but
it's no there's no practical logical
safe sense to do it
you need to get them aligned your heart
needs to say listen to me brain we're
going now help me figure out how to get
there we're jumping now let's figure out
how to make our parachute on the way
down that's how it is big decision with
the heart small ones with the head rule
number nine think big and act small the
secret to getting everything that you
want out of life is to think big and act
small think big have a huge dream create
a vision for yourself that excites you
that you want to make happen and then
act small don't let the big dream be so
big that it becomes so scary and you
never start find the smallest possible
way to just get started think big act
small otherwise your dreams will stay
exactly that rule number 10
just do you you don't do you because
you're afraid of negative judgment
you're afraid of what your family will
think you're afraid of what your friends
will think you're afraid of what total
strangers will think you'll sing in the
shower but you won't sing outside
walking down the street why it's not
because you're afraid of failing it's
because you're afraid of failing in
front of other people until you crush
that fear of judgment from other people
you will never accomplish the big goals
in your life and today i'm going to show
you how so last weekend i was in dallas
i was doing a speech at video marketing
world which is a fantastic event put on
every year in dallas where some of the
top video creators come to try to help
other people are trying to get started
in video marketing build their business
and i had a really important session at
the front
and i was nervous going into it because
i just made a big move on my youtube
channel my main channel i split into
eight or nine multiple different
channels so now instead of just running
my main channel we got channels like
this which is dedicated to its own
channel now when i was thinking about
doing a move it was recommended to me
by mac elan who's one of five people who
who i would really listen to for youtube
advice there's five people in the world
who said evan
you suck on youtube
here are the things that you should do
to get better right
i'm at the cutting edge there's five
people who would listen to one of them
is matt guillen and he told me to split
up my channel another one of the five is
jeremy vest and he told me don't do the
split up i've known jeremy for a number
of years he's helped me a lot i've
helped him a lot i really respect his
opinion he said do not split up the
channels it's better to keep them all on
one channel and so i'm faced with the
dilemma which one do i do and i decided
that i'd rather no one fail than not
know that i would rather do it because i
know what my channel looks like now
having all the videos on one channel i
know what that looks like i didn't know
what having multiple channels look like
and so i'd rather no one failed and not
know but here's the thing why do i tell
this story because when i'm in dallas
the person who was putting on the event
was jeremy vest the guy who told me not
to split up the channels the guy who
said this is a mistake you shouldn't do
it you should keep all the videos on one
channel and what did i end up doing i
did the opposite right i did what matt
said and not jeremy and so
i knew this question would come up when
i was on stage because everybody there
knew that i had split up my channels and
was wondering how it would work out
and my default response as i thought
about it was i don't want to go deep
into the story because jeremy is here in
the room and this is his event he's not
just attending he's hosting it this is
his event i don't want to make him feel
bad i don't want to make it seem like
he's on a spotter that i wouldn't want
to listen to his advice because i love
him and respect him and i love hearing
his perspective
but the fact that i was afraid of it
meant that i had to do it that's
something that i've trained myself to do
that i want you to train yourself to do
as well that the fact that you are
afraid of what somebody else is going to
say or think means you have to do it you
have to step into it you can't teach
yourself that when you think of
something and you're afraid that you
play small it's better not even to think
about it better not to catch your
insecurity when you catch it you have to
train yourself to go off and do it
and then i default to thinking okay well
how can i do this in a way that is
respectful to jeremy that is loving to
jeremy that that i i can show people how
much i appreciate his feedback that i
don't make him look bad at his own event
how can i do that and then that question
asking leads you to better answers and
so it came up
just like i thought it was going to come
up and i talked about it and jeremy
wasn't offended and jeremy did not look
bad
and i accomplished my objective
and i did it made myself feel proud
because i was nervous because i was
afraid and so that's what i want to
teach you that the next time that you're
afraid that the next time you're feeling
small the next time you're worried about
somebody else's opinions of you that you
go and you take action that you do the
thing
because you cannot play small for life
if you are worried about what people
think of you you will never accomplish
the big goals in your business because
you have big goals you're an
entrepreneur you want to do amazing
things you have big ambitions that will
never happen
if you're afraid of what one person's
gonna think of you now i've got a very
special bonus clip that i think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three point landing questions
let's go from just watching a video to
taking action here we go question number
one how will you change your perspective
today question number two what is the
one thing that you're gonna focus on
this week question number three what is
it that you're gonna start to do for
free and if you made it this far in the
video and promised to taking action
after watching i will celebrate with you
give me a hashtag believe in the comment
below
i think everyone is born an optimist and
then your environment sucks the soul out
of most people when you're a baby you
don't stress out about how you look what
you're wearing or how you're smelling
when you're a kid you don't hate your
life and complain about the world if
there's negativity in your head it was
put there by someone and if you want to
change it you need to change your
environment so i've had the good
pleasure of seeing one of my friends
mark drager a great friend of the
channel been involved with the channel
for a number of years
become more optimistic become more
positive and he was wondering could i
even do it is it possible he was a guy
who was naturally naturally pessimistic
he had a lot of stuff happen to him like
we all have a lot of situations a lot of
circumstances that made him see the the
negative of what's happening of be
pessimistic of not being the typical
optimistic everything's gonna work out
great entrepreneur and so what changed
over the past 12 months he's made a
significant investment in himself i've
been hanging around with him a lot more
we've co-hosted a podcast together he's
hanging around me my content garyvee's
content tom bill used content more he's
been to tony robbins seminar twice in
the past year brought his team with him
and he's slowly inching towards more
optimism more positivity that more
things are possible
because of the negative upbringing that
he had it takes a lot of unwiring it
takes a lot of shift in your focus it
takes a lot of with purpose with intent
changing your environment changing the
people you hang out with changing where
you the physical environment that you're
in
to make a change i went to mark's office
and he's moving his office he's creating
his own office he's putting a picture on
the wall of himself and then what he
wants to be as as positive inspiration
every day he's looking at what kind of
colors and what kind of furnishings and
and what kind of the core can i have in
my office to make me feel bold to make
me feel alive every single
day it's possible and i think that's a
starting point for a lot of people it's
possible to change your outlook it's
possible to become more optimistic that
negativity that was planted in your head
was put there by somebody else who hates
their life you are not born to wake up
and hate your life you're not born to
wake up and think that it's just
negativity all around the world you're
not born to wake up and be a pessimist
you're not it was put there by somebody
somebody else who hated their life and
we need to eject that person we need to
unwire the years or decades of training
and in that void
you replace it with the thing that you
want if you want more optimism you you
surround yourself with the most
optimistic people you can find
in person on your team in video format
in the books you read in the clubs
you're hanging out with you first limit
access from the negative people
limit exposure you may not be able to
completely wipe them out like maybe
they're your parents but you can limit
exposure you limit access either with
time or just topics that you're covering
and then inject more positivity and
optimism to the people books resources
environment that you have around
[Music]
if you want to see more of my husband
evan carmichael's top 10 rules for
success check out the video next to me i
think you're going to enjoy i'll see you
there and continue to believe the
problem isn't that you're not a genius
that you're not talented that you don't
have wisdom and abilities and resources